abbiamo già stordito sì quindi appoggio
tutti se ne sono già andati facciamo ci
sono i decisi ma poveri esseri battero
gli allucinatoria fatto un figurone mi
giu quindi secondo episodio
l'udc obama allora partiamo subito che
se batte royale e quindi ci dobbiamo
fare la granda che lingua è non lo so ma
questi spari però è veramente buono bar
o come rock e marocco marocco marocco
hanno provato la francia ma non si sono
mai stati in francia ma proprio lì che
dai voli via renato di natale
professionale non a caso un bel mare
inedito non sono la maniera di euro
detto una cazzata ma vedere di trovare
quella nostra bandiera la bandiera
va bene comunque dove stiamo dove stiamo
sul mare gelateria italiana è alto
al 12 dove cacchio siamo zio dove
scusiamo dai bene e raggiungere max che
non faccio le cose che dico
altro giro altro round siamo e usa sì
anche secondo me
oddio non lo so se potremmo anche se in
italia volta la targa lohan baia
lombardi rom valdes per fantastico è
un'italia wanna be web ma non c'è
un'indicazione pro si fa dai cosenza
ragazzo siamo non lo so io non ci credo
ma se lo prendi sto male già sto male
per il caldo sono previste o ancora
peggio no vabbè ma quando si ha paura in
questi posti non puoi farci un cavolo
dai come fai a capire perché
dopo la polonia volandia bello rosella
sensi si è uguale power time vediamo
almeno il presto ovviamente america del
sud ma non sappiamo dove ogni volta che
non sappiamo dove in america del sud è
in colombia colombia no poteva andare
meglio
lo spoglio anch'io ho pensato era uguale
non 80 all'ora del fondo è quello
ragazzi dai veramente ma il pcl league
se possiamo fare che l'america latina
non la mettiamo perché è impossibile ce
ne sono troppi ma poi ti spronano in di
quartieri residenziali dolce in avanti
tutta la zona è quella che potrebbe
essere qualsiasi cosa uno che non
approvato è la francia culo pazzesco non
ci credo non sparate a caso che culo
bravino mazze scansano parma weta dove
ci fa ma come fai
come fai signore dove siamo lei non lo
sa neanche lei c'è altra attenzione per
la superstrada che può aiutare cirillico
dai che su 5 mag
tutto qua tutto qua prenderò 2 ma tutto
qua ma quando non serve sappiamo le cose
quando non serve come saliva prendevamo
porca vacca giusto così poi prendevamo
non è tagliando ea italiana 2 hai il 2
al proprio l'italiano minano semifinale
il man iron pizzeria è il maniero quindi
siamo in america latina di città non
perdi c'è una nota panoramica generale
notte proprio per proprio a calcio
c'entra e via altre direzioni
uno l'ha azzeccata che non si sa come
sai cosa i siti punto a punto ed che
cosa appunto è canzone soraga è questa
qua sicuramente la via della primo tempo
sul posto bellissimo ma dove cazzo e poi
nella vita della moda e che cazzo di
posta e loro a me non a caso lavoro e
chiamandola in spagna andorra è uno
stato della spagna che sta e sopra sopra
vai sulla spagna qua no mi faccio a
saperlo ma stava un secondo me perché ho
letto andorra proprio quando detto vari
è andorra censito la morgue a [ __ ] da
io punto a di dice ma che cazzo d.la di
là dei maroniani lanciamo stiamo
giocando bene stiamo giocando però
facciamo dai dai ragazzi accette per
questo piace vi facciate te allora le
targhe sono particolari hanno l'azzurro
ma non ne sia nell'esatto sembra quasi
la germania direi io così la germania
sembrano un parcheggio di merda o imagna
lo investe la mia vincoliamo pazza
però non so tradotto gli invio lingue
rose bosch baggins si potrebbe essere
comunque non è che secondo me
non andrebbe essere come car non si può
uscire sono qua non esco noi stessi cioè
fuori porco del demonio maledetto ma se
avessimo parcheggiato la macchina dove
cazzo si esce il suo posto di merda
bravo già finito il tempo sono uscito
adesso cazzola spetta al bank cazzo ne
so potrebbe essere tipo landa anche
oltre che cazzo dell'olanda vabbè tempo
più su un po più su ancora ok bravo e ci
siamo anche stati solo una tavola by
narra allora ci siamo è questa questa
cosa questa che adesso ci siamo scaldati
messico messico
siamo stati quella medico ma adesso si
parte ragazzi adesso suo paglia non so
veramente basta abbiamo scherzato fine
tutti hanno bloccato perché la scritta e
nessuno ha azzeccato messico guarda come
te nome su tutti il prossimo signori
proprio noi magazine e in 3 mentre in
bilancio le parks kid and distribution
service autogas si sicuro 100 105 100
100 100 no per ora è invece vanta 20 è
buono 70 legge va bene un tale va bene
la donna a prender abc bobby proprio per
halo
bambino grande una bici un po più
proporzionata lui gliene frega niente
alla razione k
forza juve forza a cuba noi siamo
aspetta il cartello bene ero a posto e
vince nessuna delle vie micheli michele
dov'è che deve andar via micali
manca pochissimo con caputo sono state
messe lo spezia
secondo me è un paese nordico
effettivamente madonna bravo max
imbattuto questo il culo anche secolo
sempre puro comunque per quanto svezia è
un paese nordico l'era sicuro bello ma
scusa iniezione avevo visto un cartello
non enorme sì certo chiaro lo chiamò la
vuoi mettere in un senso né chiaro su 9
non annuncia un action in poi mettere in
usciremo mai di pausa euro non indovina
nessuno abbiamo perso tutti tranne
quello che sta accettando che c'è in
mezzo c'è ma come fai a me dire da genti
ero dario mecca non so devo andare vai
vai vai la parte giusta qua bello nove
ragazzi si fa noi possibile ma come non
ha parola si indovina qualcuno e c3 per
forza progress e manutenzione no
sul sembra spazio francese anche questo
sì ma non è francia è tipo quei paesi le
colonie l'ex colonie ci siamo quasi zero
tipo due parlano in francia sia in
africa e ma dove se sbagliamo tutti
teorica melo dovrebbe non è possibile ci
si azzecca velocit
chi non aspetta vai vai vai algeria
provai è impossibile ma da galera ma
figurati se madagascar si parla francese
non sia colonia porca [ __ ]
impossibile ai miei ragazzi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto oggi concludiamo
con la nostra amarezza per non aver
creduto noi stessi per avere sia
piaciuta ragazzi ma sinceramente mi
piace la stancanelli che anche capitano
se ne sta in mattinata il canale grazie
lega e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video senza telecomando
beh ragazzi già adesso
[Musica]